boa tarde
a responsabilidade opa ea
responsabilidade é o meu terceiro ted na
vida e talvez o mais difícil de todos
porque sou o último e porque resolvi
trazer meu filho de cinco meses
vamos ver o que acontece durante a
apresentação
e já que falamos de futuro eu sou
responsável por encerrar esse
maravilhoso dia a minha visão aqui é
sobre perspectivas
eu queria partilhar com vocês que o
mundo onde estamos hoje o mundo de
perspectivas e muitas vezes em todas as
nossas nosso dia-a-dia nossas empresas
nossas vidas
tudo bem a gente fica muito preocupado
com o passado o histórico a gente dirige
os nossos carros olhando para frente mas
as nossas empresas olhando para trás o
que é importante hoje
uma é olhar para frente o mais
importante é o futuro
por alguma razão quando tivemos um carro
nosso retrovisor é menor que o vidro da
frente porque o que vem pela frente é
muito mais importante do que passou
o que eu quero partilhar com vocês aqui
deixar uma mensagem pede uma mensagem de
olhar o futuro e me pediram quando me
convidaram a uns meses atrás e perguntar
você trazia o lg ou não ser bom se ele
aguentar a gente leva ele o palco é o
palestrante tese mais novo da história
achou do tet num eu queria discutir com
vocês que é o futuro que significa
futuro porque o futuro e eu que sou
professor da área de inovação sou
professor do futuro
o consultor de futuro ajudando as
empresas pelo mundo a olhar para frente
a pergunta é o que significa futuro
porque é que é tão importante hoje nós
olharmos para frente e muitos de nós
nessa geração dessa sala muitos nós
somos da geração fomos formados olhar
para trás
eu quero que ele jogue para frente se
preocupe muito mais também olhando pra
frente
do que puramente olhar para trás por
nossa histórica porque foi porque vai
ser o que interessa olhar pra frente e
futuro tem várias com vários contextos a
ética é importante não vale tudo
o futuro e radical futuro universal eu
fiz de baixo para cima de propósito é
tribal e urbana e rápido
nós somos estamos vivendo a maior
transformação da história da humanidade
e essa transformação que eu quero falar
dela pra vocês em três pilares no pilar
de pessoas num pilar de tecnologia e não
pela área de conhecimento
e quando falamos em conexão e desconexão
que é o tema do nosso ted aqui nessa
desse nosso encontro
a minha proposta é deixar uma mensagem
para vocês de que a conexão não é de
agora ela de fato ela sempre existiu só
que aconteceu uma coisa maravilhosa nos
últimos anos
nós passamos de um mundo perfeitamente
linear maioria de nós nessa sala somos
da geração em que os pais falavam estuda
arruma emprego para a vida casa tem
filhos ele está sempre no eles porque
geração do seu partido nacional e sem
doenças
não sou eu o guardo nenhum eu sou da
geração ea partir de quando os
resultados não abordar a forma de se
conhecer minimamente aquilo já é
empregado nunca seria tratada e talvez
ganhasse a vida inteira naquela empresa
e cedesse um pouquinho de tivesse o
poder de competência eu conseguiria
chegar a unção auxiliavam em 20 anos
o mundo já não é esse a maioria de nós
nessa sala somos da geração em que o tc
foi entregue em quatro esquetes de um
ponto 44 mega e ele correu quando
mostrar para ele que é uma esquete um
ponto 44 medalhas porque viver a quarta
redução salarial
aquele momento em que nós dependemos da
tecnologia dependemos da coletividade se
perguntar se nessa sala vocês preferem
ficar sem o smartphone ou sem um dedo do
pé ele responde
se formos colocar emoção de lado escolhe
o dedo pra cortar porque mais de 2 - não
faz diferença nenhuma
mas não me tira a conexão os neps eto o
instagram o bebê
então o que a gente vive é o crescimento
exponencial da conexão o crescimento
exponencial da conectividade e essa
conexão ela sempre
mas olha que coisa maravilhosa revelou
hoje que acontece no na internet 700.000
login no facebook 900 mil likes no team
leader não é possível ser só gente
solteira que está lá não acredito nisso
2.4 milhões de pesquisas no google com o
detalhe de 20% delas são novas
nunca foram perguntados antes por minuto
com isso agora faz 38 mil posts spotify
38 mil horas de música a mais vão ver
200 mil dólares por minuto o que perfaz
1.379 viagens por minuto e sendo um
minuto 24 horas 7 dias da semana 30 dias
no mês 365 dias no ano que está
acontecendo e nós achando que o mundo
está muito parado
eu escutei muitas vezes sendo o brasil
com a crise empresas vendam o mercado
está muito parado fazer nada agora vão
ficar quietos onde é que está parado
onde é que esse futuro que está chegando
está parado
a diferença é a forma de conexão mas o
mundo sempre foi conectado
o que mudou foi o de vai se foi a
ferramenta que nós usamos e essa
ferramenta só acelerou o mundo o fato e
nós dependemos nosso smartphone do nosso
tablet do que for é outra conversa
mas a conexão sempre esteve lá e muitas
vezes eu vejo as pessoas não temos que
nos conectar
temos que sair dessa confusão mas o
mundo sempre foi assim
os cinco mega promo e hard drive 5 mega
e tem aquele peso a minha apresentação
não conseguir mandar promete 85 mega
evento uma pendrive de 8gb que vai que
era necessário 8 giga do bolso versus
uma tonelada pesava os primeiros cinco
mega de conhecimento de notícia
maravilhosa incrível doc e lança celular
que envia mensagem de telefone por
telefone
aprenda a compactar uma música pra cabem
três esquetes
achei genial essa 3 disquetes uma música
quando vocês precisam colocar o spotify
e mudou que essa dói passaram 20 anos
passaram e nada na história da manhã
essa é a minha sobrinha mais velha
carolina que quando descobriram em casa
domingo mas esquetes pergunte o que é
isso
e eu falei isso aí é uma coisa de um
ponto 44 mega que entrava no mountain
dor nem sequer olhou útil você está de
sacanagem comigo você que o carro do
futuro você imprimiu em 3d
o símbolo de save do anti-viral o
simples e serviu o word e do excel eo
powerpoint saiu dessa coisa tio não é
possível não existia como é que vocês
trabalhavam e os mais novos dessa sala
isso é muito ruim pra cá muito esse
então não sabia que estavam falando aqui
né
então qual é a grande mudança da conexão
é o comportamento das crianças
procuravam balas antes e hoje procurou
ayfas que a primeira coisa que eu quero
saber como é que eu me conecto a fazer
os né post fazer o meu instagram
funcionar mostrar que estou em algum
lugar
então nosso desafio é comportamental o
filho dessa minha amiga deixou um
bilhete para ela a mãe eu amo você mais
que a minha cama netflix nutella e tudo
o resto
e ela comentou se é mais que no telenet
flix é porque é muito então então há uma
mudança comportamental de valores nas
pessoas o estranho hoje é quando alguém
não está conectado
isso não tem problema eu vejo muitas
vezes até as gerações mais velhas a
minha mãe tem 70 anos ela é tão a dica é
editado conectado o dia inteiro a minha
avó com 93 mãe e via sms mais rápido do
que eu e artrose nos dedos
então aqui uma uma questão que não é
puramente tecnológica é comportamental
eu sou da geração que quando tinha o meu
diário e todo mundo ia eu ficava puto
porque no meu diário hoje eu fico puto
sem ler o que os coloca no facebook e no
instagram então há uma mudança e essa
mudança é boa essa mudança é melhor
coisa que aconteceu na história da
humanidade o que a gente vê hoje é a
absoluta necessidade dos conectarmos e
nos conectarmos não só os outros mas a
nota em que palestras hoje sensacionais
mas alguma nova realidade que a gente
goste ou não é
essa é a nova espécie o desafio qualquer
pessoa dessa sala a ficar nessa posição
mais que três minutos já conseguiu
interagir com um tablet por muito que
vocês façam o pilates e e cross fit o
que vocês quiserem porque a geração da
galera que já está em outra conversa
na verdade ele está aqui da outra e esse
é um celular da babá que no outro dia
quando ela olhou estava na mão então nos
no reino unido os 54 por cento das
crianças confio mais no google que nos
pais
eu sou da geração quando meu pai falava
comigo eu acreditava no que ele falava
hoje aqueles que têm filhos que não é
desse tamanho o que vocês falam que o
cara vem do concurso você tem razão e
ele volta para vou te explicar e com dez
anos explica mesmo que traz embasamento
de de blogs de sites de outubro diz que
monte de coisas tudo bem bb quer pegar
ele
então o que está falando hoje o que está
acontecendo com a tecnologia mais 10
segundos por favor nunca planejaram o
assunto
além do ficando sem o meu super
divertida tudo combinando está então o
que é que isso nos fala que de fato a
nossa dependência pela tecnologia pela
conexão é cada vez maior ea tecnologia o
cuidado que a gente tem que ter com a
gente se conecta é que ela faz tanta
quem está próximo
ela tende a afastar quem está próximo e
de fato a voz e não gostou da verdade a
lógica não é então o que a gente vive é
uma mudança da pirâmide base nas
necessidades e essa pirâmide que o
maslow construiu dizendo nesse exato
fisiológica e papai eu acho maravilhosa
mas esqueceu duas coisas como agente
futuro a gente ajuda a resolver isso
imagine a vida de vocês sem bateria e
sem internet
ninguém consegue escutar o que estou
falando aqui o mundo é totalmente
diferente
então quando a gente vive uma nova
realidade de conexão que atinge todo
mundo quem impacta todo mundo o grande
desafio que nós temos como pessoas que o
grande desafio que nós temos como
profissionais e como empresas é se
preparar para essa realidade é se
preparar para essa nova vida é se
preparar para coisas dessas
siri que de trânsito é esse
e ela responde eu tivesse um outro
estaria bem vermelho agora essa é a
nossa realidade de que o mundo conectado
faz parte da nossa vida
mas de certa forma a gente leva às vezes
essa conexão tomate e o desafio o
desafio do equilíbrio é o desafio de
tentar equilibrar e aquilo que a
evolução da tecnologia a chamada e vem
aí a quinta revolução industrial em que
os robôs inteligentes vão conseguir ser
mil vezes mais rápido que o ser humano
em raciocínio a ibm tem um ótimo que faz
o download da wikipédia em um segundo
como é que eu vou combater um robô que
em um segundo pega todo o conhecimento
disponível equipe e interagir comigo
para um novo mundo e esse novo mundo
esse futuro que nós falamos ele está
mais um
identificado quando a 99 o matrix ou à
noite o esporte surgiu com touchscreen e
telas touch
ninguém acreditava que se acontecer e aí
quantos hoje de nós não vivem grudados
nas telas touch
então quando a gente olha para esse
mundo o que temos dizendo é a tecnologia
é o meio para nos conectarmos e nós
sempre estivemos conectados o que tem
mudado ao longo do tempo é a velocidade
de conexão ea forma de conexão e quando
olhamos dessa forma precisamos atualizar
precisamos nos atualizar os mais
resistentes a essa dinâmica precisam se
atualizar e os mais entusiastas já estão
normalmente naturalmente mais
atualizados
então a conexão que eu queria deixar de
mensagem para vocês é uma conexão não
tecnológica é uma conexão comportamental
claro que a tecnologia está aí para nos
ajudar
claro que a tecnologia é talvez o
acelerador da capacidade cada um de nós
vai ter que cada vez será mais para
conseguir interagir com os outros e se
diferenciar neste mundo cada vez mais
competitivo eo futuro tamanho ou menos
na piada quem quiser depois nosso site
esse mapa thala partida em 18 armazéns
para 2050 fala de política de economia
de de tecnologia de ambiente de
envelhecimento fala de tudo porque
mostra para todo mundo vai ver o mundo
vai pra coisas muito óbvia se muito
claras
de fato eu concordo que morar pouco
falando a gente entende a ser soube
dessa tecnologia faltar emoção como ele
falou da emoção fala tecnologia e o
bacana do ted agente complementassem as
apresentações mas o mundo é o mundo da
informação o mundo é uma impressão 3d
impressoras 3d vão revolucionar todos os
mercados que vocês possam imaginar
já estão revolucionando alguns já em
primo pizza em casa ontem fiz um
programa na cbn sobre a transformação da
empresa ter recebido um cara puto
dizendo isso é um absurdo
ninguém vai imprimir nada em casa
três links para ele pela boca e deixar
de ser arrogante e se atualizar
não mandei slide do da vaca essas atua
fazendo acredito que não podia mostrar
estar aqui hoje mas não tem volta
porque o que vai acontecer com a
impressora 3d e coby data tem outras
coisas acontecendo olhos biônicos já foi
feito um primeiro teste de implante
biônico ocular em que a pessoa passa a
ter uma lente dentro do ônibus mas de
óculos de lente de contato é uma câmera
implantada no olho com ligação direta ao
cérebro desenho genético eu vou escolher
o sexo ea cor dos olhos do meu filho do
próximo a ela tomar a idéia à internet
de tudo tudo conectado pessoas com
pessoas máquinas como é que as máquinas
com pessoas várias pessoas como a
máquina várias máquinas com uma pessoa
tudo conectado a pele investiu conectada
não é a objetiva o relógio é a nossa
pele
ela vem vai ter implantes subcutâneos
para interagir com as pessoas e os
implantes cerebrais como inteligência
artificial
cem bilhões de neurônios a nossa cabeça
tem hoje funcionando eu posso colocar
mais 100 bilhões
imediatamente eu posso cobrar a minha
capacidade de raciocínio e mental então
esse impacto na nossa vida
isso impacta as empresas esse impacta os
profissionais
esse impacta o relacionamento entre
pessoas e entre empresas e entre
gestores e no final o que isso quer
dizer
não tem como se conectar eu posso
pontualmente sair de uma do matrix e
pega um resort na praia para terá dois
dias de férias mas no terceiro dia sem
wifi e começa a enfrentar no quarto dia
e já tem um piripaque no que dizem ir
embora porque faça um teste se
desconecta em durante 24 horas o desafio
fazer isso se cometem ou saiam daqui
desligue o celular e só liga na segunda
feira de manhã e eu aposto que 50 80 100
pessoas estão aqui 98% não vão conseguir
e esse não é o problema o problema é
quando a gente não enxerga isso
o mundo sempre foi assim acho muito
bacana essa frase fez um ligeiro ganho
de adaptação
no século 18 tomaseto irritou os acertos
nem piam 1900 foi irritou os cocheiros
dos anos 30 tv torrado hoje pergunta
taxistas
eu não entendo porque é que quando o e
mail chegou os correios não faziam
manifestações controle meio de carta na
manga e meio não entendo que taxista faz
uma reflexão quanto móvel não tem como
parar o futuro a bom netflix irrita tv e
externa petroleiros o progresso nas
palavras do autor mente na nossa visão
como empresa como escola e minha pessoal
o futuro conectado é a ser a esperança
dos povos eo desespero dos acomodados ou
como falam um grande amigo meu pros meus
dez segundos finais temos apenas grande
resistência agora também de um tom
raivoso
se estiver com um problema de todos nós
e também pelas medidas com grandes
dificuldades de movimentação nas ruas e
novos entrantes acabam os nossos então a
conexão é isso
a conexão são pessoas e tecnologia é
cada um de nós no nosso site têm alguma
informação nos downloads essa essa
pessoa não está disponível ainda deixa
ela disponível depois mas foi um grande
prazer fazer o meu terceiro ted metade
dele com o meu filho no colo a e
encerrar esse fantástico evento
muito obrigado felicidade
[Aplausos]